let's see what we have in the xbox
series x fridge today
could it be some next-gen consoles to
unbox
we've got the series s as our appetizer
series x as main course
[Music]
so i guess we'll start with our
appetizer series s i figure i should
probably use the same knife
that i use to unbox the refrigerator
it's only fair
[Music]
wow i forgot how small the series s
is oh my goodness
previously i had had the prototype
version and then after unboxing the
playstation 5
this really does look like an appetizer
so we have
the console this box is very nicely
designed and what's this
this looks like a do not disturb door
hanger that you would find on your hotel
room
some instructions power cable hdmi cable
and the controller
so fresh so clean wow that feels nice
and some batteries i'm living my dream
right now not even joking
wow look at this it's so small
it's great because if you do want a
digital only version of the new
next-gen console this is the one for you
it's small
it's extremely portable like i think
this is going to be my travel xbox now
you can also have your storage expansion
has hdmi two usb ports ethernet power
you also have a usb a on the front as
well
this looks clean like super clean look
how good they look together
so the series s is unboxed this is
purely just an unboxing i will be doing
follow-up videos on both of these
consoles so stay tuned for that be sure
to subscribe and hit the bell so you'll
be notified when i post a new video
but now time for our main course
so the first thing that you might notice
if you saw my fridge unboxing video
this box is identical to the box that
this refrigerator came in
[Applause]
[Music]
this opened up the refrigerator came out
of it
same everything they made a complete 100
replica of this box to put that
refrigerator in i guess this is gonna be
my second unboxing of the series x
oh my god i could have cut my leg off
is it really sure like is it actually
sharp yeah
do you know how quickly you can bleed
out like very quickly
i've done research
look at this packaging this is a very
nice presentation it's just like hello
i'm here power your dreams my dreams are
powered
look at this
that is that's heavy all right
i bet we have pretty much the same stuff
in here instructions
power cable hdmi and
the controller there's something else in
here
nope here it goes
can you believe how much this looks like
the refrigerator
like this looks exactly like it
i'm shook
[Music]
the best part is even these top events
that's also on the refrigerator like
they really did
go all out they made this thing look
exact
we've got our usb expansion
ethernet hdmi and power
so here's the series x this does have a
one terabyte drive already installed in
it but it also does have an expansion
card slot so you are able to expand that
i mean some of these games are so
massive i mean even just call of duty
like waiting for those things to
download i gotta prep
a day in advance because my internet is
so terrible
so here's the series x here's the series
s
if you are looking for just a digital
version obviously this is gonna be the
way to go
this is so small and so compact you're
still gonna get your 120 hertz
refresh rate gaming which is incredible
but the size
is it's like about half
there there it's actually less than half
so small here's what they look like
laying down
the one thing with the playstation is it
does have a little stand that you have
to put it on
so that you can lay it down whereas
these do have little feet already on the
side so you can just
plop it right over the one thing that i
will not get into
is a console pc war i love everything i
love nintendo i love playstation i love
xbox i also love pc gaming
so if you're here to just kind of fight
about that just let people like
what they like you can like what you
like i don't care gaming is supposed to
be fun
so just enjoy it stop fighting even
though i know you guys aren't going to
stop fighting so
so here's the controllers i have always
been a fan of like white consoles
because most of the time a lot of my
entertainment centers
are either really dark so i like being
able to actually see the console inside
of it right now the console that i have
my main tv on
is like a really dark wood so it's
basically like my xbox is completely
lost inside of it like you can't even
see it in there
it's like active camouflage so that was
just a quick unboxing i look forward to
covering these further so
until then i will see you guys on the
internet make sure you guys follow me on
twitch for any gameplay streaming that
i'll be doing on nextgen consoles
twitter
instagram and subscribe and hit the bell
here on youtube let's see what you
look like inside the fridge i will say
though
the cooling on this thing the fridge
and the series x pretty impressive
oh my gosh did you think that this is
what
was gonna happen today
look at this i'm gonna put my controller
in the
in there that's something we did
[Music]
you